Are you excited, Paul?
Of course I'm excited.
GORBURGER:
Now, behind us
there are three human tits.
As you know, female nipples
are not allowed on television,
for some reason.
Your challenge is to decide
whether these nipples
are female
and need to be censored.
Or, Paul F., are they male,
and censorship
doesn't apply?
-You understand?
-Yes, I do.
Set the timer,
and begin.
Uh...okay, okay.
May have
a tough time here.
What do you think?
First nipple.
Is that a man,
woman or a mineral?
I think this one's a man.
All right, so it does not
need to be censored.
PAUL:
That's right.
GORBURGER:
Now, the next nipple.
Okay, this one...oh.
You can touch it.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
-That's a woman.
-That's a lady.
So that must be censored.
I see. Okay, now,
the third nipple.
[Paul blowing]
You can blow on it.
All right, now run over
to Tamimi.
-All right.
-He thinks it's a woman.
It's a woman.
So he censored
nipples 2 and 3,
and did not censor
the first nipple.
-That's right.
-All right!
Nipple number one,
please reveal yourself.
It's a man!
-Yeah. What'd I tell you?
-It was a man.
It doesn't need
to be censored.
Nipple number two,
reveal yourself.
-Oh! You were incorrect.
-I really thought that was--
That is not a nipple
that needs to be censored.
It's hard because men
and women both have them.
I guess that's the point
of the game.
Okay, nipple number three,
reveal yourself.
Aah! Suzuki!
My best friend.
They were all men.
I mean, this is a--
[all scream]
-Whoa.
-Oh, but look at his penis.
-Well...
-Are we blurring that?
Is that sexist, Paul F.?
PAUL:
The human body is beautiful.
[announcer speaking Japanese]
...except for the genitals,
which I think we can all agree
are disgusting.
[campy music plays]